Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir à tous.
Alors,
«cross road. »
Sommes-nous à la croisée des chemins ?
Plutôt, n’y sommes-nous pas,
je dirais, en permanence ?
Personnellement,
je ressens que j’ai toujours été,
plus ou moins, à la croisée des chemins.
Et en fait, aujourd’hui plus que jamais.
C’est pour ça qu’il y a quelque temps,
quand on m’a proposé d’intervenir
comme speaker pour ce TEDx,
je me suis dit :
«Waouh ! Là, il y a comme
un petit clin d’œil dans la vie.
C’est une opportunité
de partager mon expérience
et du coup, une certaine vision.»
Je me présente, je suis Jothi-Seroj,
je suis sculpteur-joaillier,
mais avant de parler de ça,
je suis une personne,
et depuis toujours, on pourrait dire
que je suis quelqu’un de passionné.
Tout me passionne,
je suis vraiment émerveillé.
En fait, je suis curieux de tout.
De tous les arts, des sciences,
de l’histoire, de la géographie,
de la géopolitique.
Il y a évidemment des choses
qui m’intéressent plus que d’autres,
mais tout m’intéresse.
Et ce qui est vrai à titre privé,
c’est également vrai
à titre professionnel.
Comme je disais,
je suis sculpteur-joaillier.
En fait, c'est vraiment comme une certaine
dominance, un goût pour l'art,
pour le beau qui prend vraiment cette
notion de précieux qui m’a amené
vers ce côté d’artiste
sculpteur joaillier.
C'est vraiment la partie la plus
artistique du domaine de la joaillerie.
Et depuis toujours, depuis même enfant,
j’étais particulièrement émerveillé
par les objets précieux.
Les objets précieux,
ça comprend beaucoup de choses.
On peut voir comme les œufs de Fabergé,
comme des coupes en cristal de roche,
qui vont être rehaussées d’or,
incrustées de diamants, de saphirs.
Ça, c’est souvent des pièces
qu’on a dans les collections royales.
On peut avoir des horloges aussi.
En Orient, il y a des choses incroyables,
comme en Inde, on peut trouver des arbres
rehaussés de diamants, d’émeraudes,
ou en Asie, en Chine, où il peut
y avoir des jades sculptés.
Toutes ces choses-là, où il y a un sens
artistique et précieux hyper développé,
qu’on trouve n’importe où dans le monde,
c’est quelque chose qui me
touche particulièrement.
Et en fait, la particularité
des objets précieux,
c’est ça qui va aussi accentuer
mon côté à la croisée des chemins,
c’est qu’on est à la fois un pied
dans la joaillerie, dans le luxe,
mais également un pied
dans l’univers de la maison,
de la décoration,
un sentiment de l’intérieur.
Ça fait deux univers.
Et dans chacun de ces univers,
il y a plusieurs petites facettes,
plusieurs métiers.
Dans ces secteurs-là,
c’est important d’avoir une certaine
connaissance, une certaine culture,
de faire des visites, d’aller dans
des musées, de lire des livres d’art,
et donc du coup de s’inspirer,
d’avoir un bagage.
Et avec ce bagage, on l’exporte.
On va faire des dessins,
des peintures, des photomontages.
Tout ce contenu que l’on crée en soi,
il faut le partager avec ses équipes,
parce que c'est toujours un travail
d'équipe, mais aussi avec ses clients.
C'est vraiment quelque chose
que l'on construit.
Une fois qu’on a une certaine vision
du projet, il faut aller plus loin,
il faut le mettre en matière.
Il faut avoir une certaine
notion du volume.
et parce qu’on fait des maquettes,
il faut avoir des aptitudes de sculpture.
Et ça, c’est un peu moins vrai,
mais c’est toujours un point clé
parce qu’aujourd’hui c’est vrai
qu’on utilise des nouveaux outils
avec les ordinateurs
et une conception en 3D
avec de l’engineering.
Mais la partie «main»,
la partie artisanale reste clé.
En effet, beaucoup de notre travail
reste l’exercice,
on va dire, le travail du métal.
Là, on va travailler sur différents
aspects, différentes techniques.
Certaines viennent du monde
de la joaillerie, vraiment,
d’autres qui vont relever
de l’usinage, de la ciselure
ou même de la sculpture
à proprement parler.
Ça, c'est pour le métal.
Et on pourrait dire que
c’est encore assez simple.
On va dans le monde de la pierre,
là, il n’y a plus de limites.
Il y a une variété incroyable de pierres,
des opaques, des dures, des tendres,
des différents types de cristaux
ou de dureté.
Et ces différentes matières, on peut aussi
les travailler de plein de manières.
On peut les tailler, on peut les sculpter,
on peut les facetter.
Tous ces aspects-là vont créer
différentes esthétiques de ce produit.
Alors il y a la pierre.
Dans une moindre mesure,
on va travailler le bois.
Il y a des bois précieux, des essences
rares qu'on peut utiliser pour des outils,
pour des pièces plus petites, mais parfois
d’une manière vraiment exceptionnelle,
il a pu m’arriver de réaliser
des meubles entièrement précieux.
Tout le meuble est fait de bois précieux
et peut être même rehaussé d'argent, d'or
et même de pierres précieuses.
Ce sont des commandes rarissimes.
J’ai eu la chance d’avoir
une commande royale dès mes 27 ans.
J’en ai eu quelques autres après.
C’est vraiment quelque chose qui marque.
Alors, il y a la pierre, le métal, le bois
et il y a aussi ce qu’on va appeler
les gemmes organiques.
Les gemmes organiques, ça va comprendre
l’ambre, le corail, la nacre,
à l’époque, l’ivoire
qu’on ne travaille plus, évidemment,
mais la manière de travailler
est encore différente.
Un autre aspect important
dans le monde des objets précieux,
c’est la mécanique.
Ce n’est pas évidemment ma partie,
mais en fait, c’est quand même
à moi de la gérer.
C’est-à-dire que beaucoup d’objets
précieux vont relever de l’horlogerie,
avec des petites horloges de table,
ou, ça peut arriver, des automates,
des œuvres d’art animées
qui vont faire une petite scène.
Évidemment, à la fin, il faut avoir
un grand sens du détail,
un goût pour les finitions,
parce qu’on parle quand même
bien de produits de luxe,
dont les valeurs sont très élevées.
Il s’agit vraiment d’avoir un goût
pour le fini et pour l’excellence.
Les détails font la perfection.
La perfection n'est pas un détail.
Vous l’avez vu, ce n’est que
pour les objets précieux.
Le gros de mon travail,
c’est la joaillerie portée.
Je fais également des montres,
où c’est très très riche.
Mais il y a un point qui...
J’appréhende mon travail
d’une manière holistique,
je le prends comme un tout.
Or c’est un secteur où tout est
très cloisonné, limite duel.
Dès l’éducation,
dès qu’on apprend à l’école,
parce qu’il y a des écoles
pour apprendre la joaillerie,
facilement, on va être orienté soit
vers la création pour faire du design,
soit vers la production
et devenir artisan.
Je ne pouvais pas choisir,
j’ai fait les deux.
Je suis plus considéré comme un artisan,
comme quelqu’un qui va produire.
Mais je suis également reconnu
pour ce que je vais imaginer,
pour ce que je vais créer,
en tant qu’artiste.
Et justement, je me considère
avant tout comme un artiste.
Or la folie, le hasard, la vie a fait que
je me suis mis à mon compte à 21 ans.
Cette fibre entrepreneur est très marquée.
Je suis designer et artisan,
artiste et entrepreneur.
Normalement, c’est séparé.
Il y a aussi un dernier point,
même si cette tendance s’atténue,
c’est que, soit on travaille pour une
grosse marque, une grande marque de luxe,
soit on crée la sienne.
J'ai fait les deux.
Le gros de mon travail reste de travailler
pour des maisons de luxe.
Mais j’avais également
mes propres créations
et j’ai poussé, poussé cet amalgame
de telle manière qu’aujourd’hui il arrive
même que je co-signe pour des clients,
que je signe avec eux pour des marques.
Alors,
j’ai fait le choix de ne pas choisir.
Je ne pouvais pas, tout me passionne.
Je ne pouvais pas privilégier.
C’était choisir l’un, choisir l’autre ?
Non, impossible.
Il me faut faire les deux.
Mais comme le corps est limité,
je ne peux pas me dédoubler, hélas.
J’adorerais avoir plusieurs moi-même,
mais ce n’est pas possible.
Alors, j’ai été forcé naturellement
de créer mon propre chemin.
Ma propre voie.
Et créer son propre chemin,
c’est comme dans la nature.
C'est super dur.
On n'a pas de route établie.
Il faut y aller.
C'est comme traverser une forêt vierge.
C'est très, très violent.
C'est très violent parce que d'abord,
on sort d'un cadre.
Les gens, eh bien,
ont besoin d’une certaine simplicité.
Ils ont besoin souvent de mettre
une étiquette sur quelque chose,
sur quelqu’un, de réussir à le comprendre.
Là, il y a beaucoup de choses
à comprendre, trop.
Et donc du coup, on peut
en subir une forme de rejet.
Ce n’est pas le plus grave.
C’est bien plus embêtant,
quand on choisit plusieurs chemins ainsi,
eh bien, on étale ses ressources.
On étale, on s’épuise.
On étale ses ressources,
son temps, son argent, son énergie.
Il y a ce risque de la dispersion.
Comment faire pour réussir
à faire plusieurs choses en même temps,
sans être complètement perdu ?
En fait, malheureusement,
dans mon propre cas,
j’ai eu beaucoup de mal à réussir
à comprendre ça.
Et on compense, on compense
avec du sacrifice,
beaucoup de sacrifices, du temps.
C’est un certain choix de la difficulté.
J’ai dû sacrifier littéralement
tout mon temps.
Pendant des années, j’ai travaillé
littéralement jour et nuit, jour et nuit,
les week-ends, pas de vacances, rien.
Toujours avancer, avancer, avancer
vers une certaine vision.
J’y ai sacrifié le gros du
concept d’une vie privée.
Les relations de couple,
les amis que l’on ne voit jamais,
la famille qu’on ne voit jamais.
Alors des choses pas très graves,
mais quand même,
comme l’argent pour aller en vacances,
pfff, à la trappe !
Des choses bien plus embêtantes,
comme une partie de ma santé.
Mais alors attention, soyons bien clair.
Dit ainsi, on pourrait penser
que c’est super noir.
Je ne regrette absolument rien.
C’est juste...
Tous ces choix ont été faits
globalement plutôt en conscience.
J'ai suivi une certaine vision.
La difficulté n'est pas un problème.
Plusieurs choses font
qu’on ne peut pas regretter.
D’abord quand qu’on regrette,
c’est un danger.
Ça veut dire choisir d'être malheureux.
Moi, je ne suis pas malheureux,
je suis très heureux.
S’il y a bien une seule chose qu’on peut
choisir dans la vie, c’est son état.
J’estime qu’être heureux ou malheureux,
c’est une question de personne.
C'est une question de choix.
Ça ne dépend pas de sa situation
sociale, ni de ses finances.
Il y a des gens très riches
qui sont malheureux,
des gens très pauvres qui sont très bien.
Donc, c’est vraiment
une question de choix.
Ensuite, l’autre point très important,
qui fait que je ne regrette rien,
c’est que tous mes choix,
les bons et les mauvais,
m’ont permis d’apprendre
et à vrai dire, surtout les mauvais.
C’est vraiment dans la difficulté
qu’on trouve des ressources nouvelles.
Il faut savoir sortir
de sa zone de confort.
On sait très bien que dans
sa zone de confort, on stagne,
voire on recule, parce que
le monde continue de tourner.
C’est vraiment un point clé.
Et je dirais que dans mon cas,
j’ai été en permanence dans une zone
de non-confort, d’inconfort.
Et ce grand inconfort
permet d’acquérir des aptitudes.
On est obligé d’être plus fort,
plus combatif, de prendre une distance,
d’être plus créatif et puis de s’adapter,
donc, de gagner en souplesse.
Et en fait, c’est avec cette force acquise
et cette souplesse acquise
qu’on trouve une forme d’équilibre.
De la même manière qu’au quotidien,
il s’agit de faire des choix,
et même parfois des choix difficiles.
Dans mon cas, j'essaye d'être équilibré
entre la logique et l'intuition.
Et de les peser.
Ce n’est pas prendre parti
pour l’un ou pour l’autre, non.
C’est d’essayer de trouver
une harmonie et un équilibre
dans ces différentes facettes
de qui je suis.
C’est un chemin qui est
quand même très particulier.
Concrètement, c'est un métier de niche.
J’ai choisi un métier insolite
et je suis moi-même insolite
dans mon métier qui l’est.
Et ce chemin-là a fait que,
malgré tout, on sort du lot.
J’ai eu la chance de rencontrer
certaines de mes idoles,
des pairs, des gens qui étaient
des grands du métier.
À peu près une grande partie
des grands acteurs de mon secteur,
de mes secteurs, devrais-je dire, vu que
je suis dans plusieurs mondes à la fois.
Je les ai admirés, ils m’ont inspiré.
Et puis,
je continue, j’innove.
En fait, le fait d’avoir ce chemin
si insolite, si particulier,
m’a permis d’avoir des opportunités,
d’avoir des commandes d’exception,
de rencontrer et de travailler
pour des altesses royales,
pour des personnalités des arts,
de la politique, à très très haut niveau,
d’exposer dans des lieux très prestigieux
à l’étranger, en France,
à Monaco, à Dubaï, à Londres,
au Louvre ou au Grand Palais.
Ça m’a aussi permis de participer
à des œuvres de charité,
à des événements sportifs,
et de partager mon savoir et une partie
de mes revenus pour de justes causes.
Tout ça avance.
Et puis évidemment, on finit par avoir
une certaine forme de reconnaissance.
Mon travail intéresse et puis on en vient
à paraître publié dans des journaux,
dans des magazines, de faire même
éventuellement une couverture.
Ça n'est pas une fin en soi.
C’est plutôt comme...
Ça fait plaisir, mais ce n’est pas
une vraie satisfaction :
on ne fait pas ça pour ça.
C'est juste la partie émergée de l'iceberg
de tout un travail préparatoire.
Le temps a passé.
Je me suis mis à mon compte très jeune,
21 ans, avec seulement 1 000 €,
sans amis, sans connaissance
vraiment dans le métier.
C’était vraiment juste porté
par la passion, par la folie même.
Et voilà,
j’étais avec 1 000€ à travailler tout
seul dans ma kitchenette à Paris.
Et aujourd’hui, j’ai 35 ans.
Et j’ai repris un local d’exception
dans un ancien palace
et j’y fais une sorte de club,
un club privé - showroom -
qui traite du monde du luxe, des arts,
de la décoration et de l’aménagement
d’intérieur de luxe.
Ce projet-là me permet de couvrir
plein de facettes de mes goûts.
Là je parle carrière, je parle travail,
mais il n'y a pas que ça.
On est aussi des personnes.
Et même si on pourrait croire
que je n’étais que là-dedans -
la vérité, c’est que
le gros de mon temps y est -
il y a aussi des rapports
humains qui se créent.
Moi, je suis devenu ami avec la plupart
de mes collaborateurs,
la plupart de mes clients,
de mes fournisseurs.
Il y a un vrai rapport humain
qui se développe.
Et même, c’est grâce au fait que j’ai
travaillé le week-end à une heure indue
que j’ai pu rencontrer l’amour.
En fait,
je ne cloisonne pas les différents
aspects de ma vie.
Tout est fluide.
Ce chemin,
c’est mon chemin.
C’est un chemin qui est un peu difficile,
dur, mais passionnant.
Dans la vie,
ce chemin-là, c’était vraiment le choix de
la passion, plutôt que celui du confort.
Je ne suis pas un modèle en soi,
clairement.
L’important, c’est vraiment
que dans la vie,
on est toujours plus ou moins
à la croisée des chemins.
On choisit en permanence.
Chaque action, chaque pensée même,
vous oriente.
Et c’est pour ça que le vrai vrai point,
c’est que chacun choisisse sa propre voie.
Peu importe que ce soit un chemin établi
ou un chemin tracé.
Pour que le jour où il s’arrête
et qu’on se retourne,
qu’on soit fier du chemin parcouru.
Merci à vous.
(Applaudissements)